là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la franche au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le front fais les valises à paris
de ce qui lui arrive à la baule comme
chaque semaine france info et inna vous
offre un voyage dans le temps à travers
les archives de la télévision pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité contemporaine
celle inattendue
vous êtes les bienvenus à mes côtés
camille d'auxerre et ludivine lopez
journaliste à la rédaction de l'ina
bonjour à toutes les deux alors ludivine
vous avez choisi de revenir sur un coup
de tonnerre politique et médiatique
c'était il y a dix ans quelle affaire
c'était le 15 mai 2011
en 24 heures souvenez-vous dominique
strauss kahn passait de patron du fmi et
probable candidat à l'élection
présidentielle probable probable et
surtout bien placé dans les stalles il
était en bonne voie donc y passer
effectivement de ce statut là à un
suspect du commissariat à harlem à new
york une femme de chambre l'accusé
d'avoir tenté de vouloir l'agresser
sexuellement un tremblement terre vous
l'avez dit nathanaël et ces images qui
ont fait le tour du monde
une sortie en pleine nuit et en pleine
lumière
encadrés par cinq policiers en civil il
est 23h à new york 5 heures du matin à
paris le prévenu mains dans le dos et
menotté sort du commissariat d'harlem
dominique strauss-kahn le visage grave
regarde droit devant lui
en face des dizaines de caméras et de
photographes deux policiers
l'accompagnent sur la banquette arrière
puis la voiture s'éloigne lentement ses
avocats eux tente une première
conférence de presse il a l'intention de
se défendre vigoureusement contre toutes
les accusations après plusieurs mois de
procédure les charges pesant sur dsk
sont finalement définitivement annulée
par la justice
et fin 2012 une transaction d'un million
et demi de dollars entre les deux
parties clôture est définitivement la
sphère du sofitel de new york
voilà les françois hollande est devenu
et président de la république alors
qu'amy vous vous êtes intéressé ou à
l'écriture inclusive
d'abord un petit rappel c'est quoi
l'écriture inclusive alors l'écriture
inclusive c'est une écriture qui se veut
plus égalitaire et qui veut rentrer donc
plus visible plus audible le féminin
dans la langue française
on en parle depuis plusieurs années par
exemple dans la féminisation des métiers
mais la semaine dernière le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer en a interdit son utilisation à
l'école alors ok pour la féminisation
des métiers de certaines fonctions mais
non au point médian le point médian
késako et là c'est ce qui permet
finalement de mettre un terme à la règle
grammaticale du masculin qui l'emportent
sur le féminin au pluriel exemple comme
à l'école ne plus écrire par exemple
électeurs avec un s mes électeurs points
rice point s et bien ça c'est interdit
maintenant à l'école et on va donc
apprendre
oui bonne nouvelle non non non c'est
bien ça ça va peut-être simplifiée aussi
l'orthographe à l'école bas peut-être
mais en tout cas on va revenir
finalement à la règle grammaticale
normale du masculin qui l'emportent sur
le féminin comme on l'enseigné dans
cette école primaire en 1990 si on
devait parler d'elle en même temps quel
mot employer ton lll avec un s et puis
le garçon propos bien et si on devait
parler de tous les enfants ensemble
quels mots pourrait-on côtoyé il est
combattu écrire est il avec un s ça veut
dire il n'ya plus de petites filles tout
est devenu garçons le masculin l'emporté
sur le féminin
c'est comme s'ils n'y avaient pâti et
bien voilà comme disait cette petite
fille c'est comme s'il n'y avait selon
lui deux petites filles est à méditer
merci beaucoup camille voilà ça c'était
pour l'actualité de cette semaine et que
s'est il passé le 12 mai à travers le
temps regardez c'est le zapping de l'ina
et ça s'est passé à 12 mètres 6 6
bonjour
apprenez à connaître votre infirmière
c'était le thème choisi aujourd'hui pour
cette journée internationale de
l'infirmière une journée organisée dans
notre pays par lan fidh
il est vrai que l'on connaît mal une
progression qui exige de ceux qui
l'exercent un dévouement au moins égale
aux compétences ce soir jacqueline
maillan n'était pas sur scène à la
comédie des champs elysées pour jouer
pièce montée après un premier malaise
cardiaque il y a quelques jours elle
s'est éteinte cet après midi à son
domicile parisien
ce soir le monde du théâtre est en deuil
la maille ans est parti mais reste son
sourire depuis juin 1948 est coupé du
reste de l'europe est aujourd'hui le
jour se lève sur berlin après les
résultats de la conférence de new york
et bientôt la solution du problème de
berlin
[Musique]
c'est le virus a frappé des dizaines de
milliers d'ordinateurs dans une centaine
de pays
du jamais vu parmi les victimes
l'entreprise de télécommunications
espagnol telefonica
le géant américain de livraison fedex ou
encore plusieurs ministères russes jean
dubuffet et mordent inventeur de l'art
brut
il n'a commencé à peindre cac 40 ans et
il aura été contestée jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie
[Musique]
bonsoir et à demain
c'est un conseil municipal absolument
surréalistes auquel ont assisté les élus
de la commune de paimpol c'est dans les
côtes d'armor
l'ancien maire de la commune a donné du
ma cocotte maîtresse à celle qui lui a
succédé un échange choquant qui a
d'ailleurs fait la une de plusieurs
quotidiens et pas seulement ceux de la
région des propos sexistes immédiatement
dénoncé par l'élu en séance et sur son
compte twitter regarder un en tout cas
un vrai cas d'école du sexisme en
politique ludivine ça n'est
malheureusement pas la première fois et
ce n'est surtout pas la première fois
que des élus dénoncent ce sexisme en
politique
c'était il ya vingt ans en 2001 des
femmes mères en parler à la télévision
sur le plateau de france 3 lille moi
c'est la première campagne où je souffre
dans ma dignité de femme
franchement je n'ai jamais vécu ça
c'était l'horreur et j'ai eu des
caricatures je sais pas si ça rendra
beaucoup et j'atterris un endroit bien
placé de ma personnalité sur le clocher
d'une église et je pense que ça je vais
saisir les chiennes de garde à paris
parce que je crois qu'il faut se
révolter contre ces méthodes et vous
annie cardon vous avez souffert de
misogynie oui une femme qui arrive et là
c'était c'était impossible ou une femme
air franchement heureux c'était
complètement débile j'ai eu ces mots
débile bidon enfin le machisme en
politique ludivine on retrouve aussi au
sein des grandes institutions de notre
république
et malheureusement les exemples sont
nombreux dans les archives je vous en ai
sélectionné quelques-uns le premier
c'était il ya pile 30 ans le jour où
edith cresson devenait premier ministre
vous allez voir c'est croustillant les
gratter
chez pour misogynie bonne façon je la
vois bien mais ailleurs je vois bien
chez elle en train de calvin ajouté
disant voilà c'était le 15 mai 1991
edith cresson été nommé premier ministre
par françois mitterrand une première en
france
et dès le début de son mandat la
socialiste devenu la cible d'attaqués
misogyne dans la rue et surtout au sein
de la classe politique
on est dans un système incroyablement
monarchie regardez le parcours de madame
de pompadour regardait le parcours
d'edith cresson il ya un parallélisme
certains edith cresson comparé à la
marquise de pompadour maîtresse du roi
louis carzou ces injures sexistes elle
en connaîtra d'autres au coeur de
l'assemblée nationale et elle ne sera
pas la seule en 1999
roselyne bachelot l'évoquait elle était
alors député rpr
c'est par exemple une femme ministre qui
répond à une question et j'entends dans
les travées à poil on est d'abord
toujours jugé sur son physique et sur
son apparence avant d'être jugé sur ce
qu'on dit sur ce qu'on pense pourquoi on
se bat le physique plutôt que les
compétences des années plus tard ce
machisme ambiant s'illustrait toujours
au palais bourbon
en 2012 la robe bleue de cécile duflot
en émoustiller plus d'un madame cécile
duflot ministre de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement
monsieur le président le coûteux
mesdames et messieurs les députés mais
surtout messieurs visiblement en 2013 la
prise de parole de la députée véronique
massonneau inspirait des cris de foule à
l'un de ses homologues
on se suffit de cliquer ici
j'ai pas une poule 1 c'est bon et en
2014 un député refusait carrément de
respecter le titre de sandrine mazetier
alors vice présidente de l'assemblée
nationale
merci madame j'en profite dans
d'introduction puisque madame ça va pas
non vous m'avez mener c'est non non non
non non alors monsieur aubert n'avait
plus la parole soit vous respectez la
présidence de séance
soyez un problème je ressens c'est
madame la présidente je n'en dise le
terrain rien rappel à l'ordre avec
inscription
ces attitudes machistes en politique
sont régulièrement dénoncées dans les
médias en octobre 2000 celle des
collaboratrices parlementaire ouvrait
même un blog pour répertorier ces
remarques sexistes
alors le blog du collectif cheikh
collaboratrice existe toujours en 2019
il publiait les résultats d'une enquête
au total la moitié des assistantes
parlementaires ayant répondu à l'enquêté
disait avoir été victime ou témoin de
blagues sexistes ou sexuelles rien que
ça et une collaboratrice sur cinq disait
avoir été victime d'une agression à
caractère sexuel
en tout cas les mentalités ont
visiblement du mal à changer ce malgré
les différentes lois de parité qui ont
été votées ces dernières années et
pourtant les femmes vous l'avez tous
constaté un sont de plus en plus
nombreuses dans la vie politique
aujourd'hui l'assemblée nationale par
exemple compte 228 députés femmes contre
155 en 2012 la part des femmes dans les
conseils municipaux est passée de 33 à
42 % en vingt ans mais visiblement ce
n'est pas suffisant à faire changer les
mentalités
mais on est encore loin de la parité
merci beaucoup lui dit ville
[Musique]
c'est une épidémie dans l'épidémie
depuis l'apparition du coc vide les
théories du complot se multiplient
l'origine de l'épidémie et la
dangerosité des vaccins y en a beaucoup
les thèses complotistes il y en a un
petit peu pour tous les goûts si vous me
passez l'expression dernièrement
d'ailleurs sur un tout autre sujet
l'enlèvement de la petite mia un
enlèvement dont le mobile est pour le
moins farfelue les enfants placés par
les services sociaux alimenterait un
réseau de pédocriminalité nist alors
avec nous pour parler de tout ça rudy
reichstadt un spécialiste bonjour vous
êtes le fondateur de l'observatoire du
conspirationnisme est surtout l'auteur
de l'opium des imbéciles
et c'est sur la question complotistes
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya de plus en plus
de théorie du complot est ce que ça vous
inquiète
alors ça m'inquiète oui évidemment parce
que ça a des conséquences on en voit
régulièrement les effets de ces théories
du complot le capitole le 6 janvier 2021
et des passages à l'acte violents cinq
morts quand même parce que les gens
croyaient qu'on leur avait volé
l'élection
alors pourquoi y en a plus il y en a
plus parce que cette théorie du complot
elle bénéficie d' dans une configuration
technique médiatique qui leur donne une
chance historique un support de
propagation exactement qui en fait une
démultiplication des moyens de diffusion
de ces théories du complot qui autrefois
était assez confidentielle et est resté
en tout cas cantonnés dans leur nombre
dans les marches politique dans
l'extrémisme politique et qu'il a un
trou avec internet un nouvel auditoire
et de nouvelles manières de se déployer
alors les théories du complot venez
parler de certaines particulièrement
récente mais camille il ya des théories
du complot vieille comme le monde
oui vieille comme le monde deux exemples
au moyen-âge épidémie de peste noire un
tiers de la population disparaît en
europe et qui est ce qu on accuse les
juifs il aurait tant poids zone et l'eau
des puits au début du 20e siècle les
protocoles des sages de sion pour
résumer c'est un texte qui rendraient
compte d'une réunion secrète de chef de
la communauté juive qui voudrait dominer
le monde une théorie qui quand même va
parcourir le monde et plus récemment
1969 un secret sera content
entre jeunes filles des femmes seraient
enlevés dans des cabines d'essayage de
magasins tenus par des juifs c'est la
fameuse rumeur d'orléans une camarade de
classe n'avertit en disant tu sais voilà
ce qui se passe à orléans des magasins
sont incriminés dans la traite des
blanches
enfin deux qui donnent et elle sait de
cette rumeur
c'était par sa belle-soeur c'était
arrivé face aux stars arrivées à la
femme d'un ami que sa belle-soeur mai se
déroulait sous forme de petites
conversations particulière de de secret
qui se serait glissée dans chaque
oreille qui aurait été répétée par tout
le monde malgré tout cette rumeur
d'orléans elle s'appuie sur un roland
antisémite c'est commun dans les thèses
complotistes sa de s'appuyer sur le
racisme l'antisémitisme me oui c'est un
saint
clairement un levier de mobilisation
très fort parce qu'il s'agit de désigner
des boucs émissaires en fait dans le
conspirationnisme là ça fait écho à une
histoire de traite des blanches en fait
l'idée qu'on alimente des réseaux de
prostitution comme ça tout un imaginaire
de la mise en esclavage sexuel et sert à
ça des réminiscences jusqu'à aujourd'hui
à travers le mouvement qu elle donne par
exemple sur les femmes c'est sûr les
enfants qu on enlèverait et dans les
deux cas
dans les deux cas il ya tout un
imaginaire de la crypte du souterrain
delà de la cave qui est commun
d'ailleurs assez à toutes ces théories
du complot ça c'est le complot d'orléans
il ya des théories du complot
particulièrement célèbre des théories
qui ont encore du succès aujourd'hui
cabinet oui ce sont les fameuses grandes
théories du complot finalement qui
perdure pour preuve ce sujet au journal
de france 2 en 2018
l'assassinât du président kennedy le 11
septembre 8 français sur 10 croient tôt
- à une de ces théories du complot les
jeunes ils seraient les plus réceptifs
32% des français croirait par exemple
que le virus du sida a été créé en
laboratoire et 9% que la terre n'est pas
ronde mais plate
l'une des théories les plus ancrées la
voici
les premiers pas de l'homme sur la lune
en 1969 ne serait qu'une mise en scène
filmée dans un studio de cinéma par
stanley kubrick lui même parmi ces
théories du complot particulièrement
c'est pour vous quelle est la meilleure
la plus grande théorie du complot
c'est difficile de les classer comme
cela ce qui est sûr c'est que le stade
suprême du complotisme c'est ce qu'on
appelle le platine
c'est l'idée que la terre est plate et
par ronde et qu'il y aurait un vaste
contrôle à un complot universel de tous
les scientifiques de caen thomas pesquet
et prend des photos depuis la station
spatiale en fait une main en effet
partie du complot également voilà donc
ça suppose quand même de considérer que
le mensonge est partout omniprésent 8
français sur 10 qui croient au moins à
une de ses ses théories c'est inquiétant
pas en fait
ce sondage je connais bien parce que
j'ai participé à cette enquête on
s'aperçoit que les gens qui croient
aucune théorie du complot ou une ou deux
ou à peu près les mêmes comportements
qui sont pas forcément intoxiqué et
perdu pour la cause en revanche ceux qui
adhèrent à 5 ou plus et qui ont des
comportements assez similaires y compris
en termes d'adhésion à des choses
complètement folles
ça va de l'astrologie et la voyance en
passant par créationnisme ses terres à
eux ils sont entre un quart et un
cinquième de la population donc oui
c'est quelque chose de tangible qui
traverse toute la société
une croyance c'est pas grave 5 il faut
commencer à sa s'inquiètent et là on est
dans un imaginaire du coup on est dans
quelque chose de plus de plus
structurant en préparant les missions
vous m'avez dit aussi qu'elle joue si ma
surprise c'est que une grande majorité
des français croient que la mort de lady
di n'est pas un accident mais un
assassinat alors pas une grande majorité
une grande majorité connaît cette
théorie est une part importante un tiers
ouais y adhèrent oui enfin voilà est
sûre c'est à dire c'est déjà beaucoup
mais oui c'est une des théories du
complot les plus à la fois les plus
connus et comment il explique ça on
explique parce que ça a beaucoup ému
parce que c'est quelque chose auquel on
n'a pas envie de croire au cirque que la
théorie du complot elle nous rend des
services psychologiques dessine réalité
alternative parce que précisément on n'a
pas envie de croire que le destin de
cette princesse s'est terminé comme ça
aussi bêtement accidentellement alors
point commun de nombreuses théories du
complot
mais la défiance des élites 1 oui et il
y a une théorie complotiste qui
symbolise très bien cette défiance
envers les lieux de pouvoir envers paris
c'est la rumeur d'abbeville
alors je replante le décor pour ceux qui
ne savent pas ce que c'est nous sommes
en 2001
la somme des bordes inondation de la
vallée des milliers de sinistrés est une
rumeur
on aurait depuis paris détourner les
eaux pour éviter que la capitale soit
inondée regarde soudain lionel jospin
est interpellé par les abbevillois la
somme serait qui m'ont dit pour épargner
des crues dans la région parisienne on
peut imaginer que quelqu'un décide à
paris je sais pas quoi d'aller noyer la
somme ça n'a pas de sens
donc ne croyait pas à ça qui voulez-vous
qu'ils aient la possibilité de à paris
le décidez de débarras l'on prenait
vraiment pour des imbéciles surface mais
je vous vous nous prenez pour des
imbéciles monsieur jospin il est premier
ministre à l'époque ça revient souvent
ça aussi ce fait de dire mais nous on a
tout compris en fait ne prenez pas pour
des imbéciles ah oui et puis c'est aussi
le signe d'une très grande détresse on
est des gens qui sont sinistrés qui ont
l'impression d'être abandonnés par pari
par le pouvoir central pendant des jours
du mal à faire savoir ce qui se passait
pour eux la part des grands médias qui
sont intéressés avec un peu de décalage
donc ça nourrit évidemment ce type de
fantasmes il ya l'idée qu'on aurait
ouvert un robinet quelque part pour
sauver paris parce qu'au même moment à
paris aussi une explication qui a
dessiné
on a le comité international olympique
qui vient pour examiner les candidatures
parisienne donc on dit en fait et on est
à un an des présidentielles et lionel
jospin bien déminé lui-même cette rumeur
ça veut dire qu'ils apprennent quand
même très très au sérieux
à quoi ça sert une une théorie du
complot mais ça sert je voulais dire à
se rassurer
parfois pour ceux qui adhèrent ça peut
servir pour ceux qui le mettent en
circulation et qui les amplifie à
manipuler les gens tout simple c'est un
outil politique c'est un outil politique
de stigmatisation sa compagne des
persécutions entre l'histoire ça permet
de faire diversion de dire vous voyez on
n'a pas échoué
on fait face à une cinquième colonne et
des gens qui sabotent notre action et
c'est donc c'est dans la boîte à outils
des leaders populistes des régimes
dictatoriaux depuis des temps
immémoriaux tournant dans les théories
du complot l'année 2000 là on ya un
avant et un après qu'il ya pourquoi un
avant et un après déjà parce qu'il ya
l'apparition des réseaux sociaux qui
vont forcément aider à la propagation de
ces théories ch
et puis il ya la vague d'attentats
terroristes au même moment les thèses
complotistes pullulent sur internet
exemple après l'attentât charlie-hebdo
l'attentât dans les locaux de charlie
hebdo venait à peine de se produire
qu'elle circulait déjà sur internet des
rumeurs commencent à sec en va pas de
sang sur la vidéo où ahmed se fait tuer
étrange non
vous êtes tous naïf pour croire que la
sphère charlie est un simple attentats
les rétroviseurs semble changer de
couleur entre deux photos
c'est donc que les terroristes ont
utilisé plusieurs voitures amedi
koulibaly semble se tenir les mains lors
de l'assaut
c'est donc il était menotté sans parler
du jour du 7 janvier qui en date
américaine devient le 17
numéro de police secours comme le 11
septembre faisait 911 numéro d'appel
d'urgence aux états unis où le tracé de
la marge du 11 janvier qui pour certains
dessiner les frontières d'israël
pourquoi est ce que les attentats
terroristes sont l'occasion thèses
complotistes c'est quoi c'est
l'incompréhension c'est ce caractère
exceptionnel et presque traumatique du
sujet qui suscite ça et puis ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que ça montre
bien qu'aujourd'hui le complotisme est
un révisionnisme en temps réel est
requise il porte même pas sur la version
officielle qui parfois même pas eu le
temps d'être articulé mais sur
l'événement en train de se faire en
quelques secondes en quelques minutes on
a des gens qui plaque en fait l'heure
leur vision préconçues des choses sur la
réalité en train de se dérouler et donc
c'était pas le cas par un plan 2001 au
monde et on sait des attentats du 11
septembre il a fallu quelques jeux à
part quelques semaines là c'est immédiat
c'est en quelques minutes
et surtout on a des gens qui sont des
enquêteurs improvisé qui se met avec
juste leur écran d'ordinateur et un
compte youtube a expliqué que regarder
ça peut pas être la même voiture
on nous ment tout ça est une mise en
scène alors comment est-ce qu'on combat
une théorie du complot on a vu lionel
jospin calé sur le terrain en 2001
depuis les réseaux sociaux ont pris une
ampleur phénoménale c'est peut-être plus
compliqué d'aller faire du porte-à-porte
en expliquant que non non pas du tout
d'abord on les combat sur leur terrain
c'est à dire sur internet de toutes
façons la pensée unique sur internet
maintenant est les complotistes
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
donc il faut je crois faire un travail
de vérification des faits de des booking
de démystification de ces théories de
ses argumentaires complotistes ben voilà
on a des arguments qui ébranle les
certitudes des gens c'est normal d'être
ébranlés par ces choses là il ya un
pouvoir
comment dire d'intimidation intellectuel
très forts de ces théories du complot
donc faut répondre aux arguments
moi je pense qu'il faut pas répondre aux
désinformateurs et aux mercenaires la
désinformation parce que entrer dans un
débat avec eux c'est légitime et
sélectionné alors que a priori non pas
aucun souci la vérité des faits cela dit
freddy reichen si je me fais l'avocat du
diable
est-ce que c'est finalement c'est
possible aussi un complot est-ce que
c'est déjà arrivé est ce qu'on peut
aussi donner une valeur parfois les
théories vous avez même parler des
protocoles des sages de sion qui est une
forme d' opération d'intoxication de
manipulation donc lutter contre les
théories du complot c'est pas du tout
dire que les complots n'existe pas un
gré manipulation n'existe pas ça existe
partie l'histoire humaine simplement les
théories du complot l on fait aussi
l'histoire elles ont poussé les hommes à
agir et parfois avec des conséquences
tout à fait funeste donc c'est ça qu'on
critique on est à un an de la prochaine
présidentielle faut-il s'attendre à une
multiplication des thèses complotistes
dans les prochains mois les prochaines
semaines
ça c'est très difficile à dire ouais
ouais faut être vigilant ça c'est
certain après çà et là où le péril croît
croît aussi ce qui sauve c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui vous avez plus d'anti
complotistes sur les réseaux sociaux
plus de médias mêmes citoyens qui
luttent contre ces choses là qu
auparavant et dont on sait qu'au début
des années 2000 exactement
exactement donc je pense qu'il faut
aussi compter avec avec ça et se dire
que le pire est jamais sûr
voilà j'en profite pour saluer nos amis
de
mais au fait que vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les semaines sur sur france info
rudy reichstadt merci beaucoup je
rappelle que vous êtes l'auteur de
l'opium des imbéciles et c'est sur la
question complotistes un sujet en tout
cas très intéressant
voilà et puis si vous voulez vous
documenter encore un petit peu plus sur
les théories du complot n'hésitez pas à
lire mentor c'est le premier numéro de
ce nouveau magazine que l'on doit à
erwann menthéour faso complotisme gare
au relativisme un très bon article
d'emmanuel rivière voilà avant de
refermer cette inattendue notre
traditionnel pépite cette semaine c'est
une archive de 1948 avec l'accent du
midi jacques martin chante notre bonne
bière à quelques jours de l'ouverture
des terrasses avec ça tombe plutôt bien
[Musique]
car les plantes pareil et comme dans la
vie on croirait gloire dans les années
paires nationale pour la moto de colère
quelle boisson idéale pour les amarres
vers là-bas dans chaque hémisphère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on se retrouve mercredi prochain
toujours à 22 heures toujours sur le
canal 27 en attendant vous pouvez bien
sûr de retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
que ce soit ceux de l'ina ou ceux de
france info émission préparée avec les
documentalistes anne delavaux laurence
mattioli merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]